do come over play hoops with us mean
deep play hoops every Thursday honey
flame hey when's the last time huh slice
doing rocks dude
the last hoops I played I played about a
year ago dude I almost fought this
[ __ ] Persian dude he's being an
[ __ ] they play real D don't the hosts
Persians take it way too serious yeah
yeah it was like it was like an L a kind
of Persian guy you try selling a carpet
afterwards he had like slaves on the
side yeah that's a gold here the gold
piercing in the nose well he left on a
ship full of gold very intense pretty
hairy too right
oh geez you like Cologne ah yeah his big
defensive move was he just wrapped a
bunch of hair around you by like hoops
isn't your thing
oh dude hoops is definitely my thing bro
probably what probably I was probably
pretty I was a good pretty good
who's player yeah sounds like it I took
long enough to get out hey did you uh
did you play sports growing up though
yeah man like what was your thing though
like did you gravitate towards anything
besides I owe towards let me see uh
outdoor activities for nice hmm
a little bit of kites man this [ __ ]
what's the last time so some people
would shoot him people would shoot him
down where I was from bro when's the
last time y'all so do talk about a drone
when's the last time someone flew a kite
oh I saw a couple in Santa Monica the
other day on 4th of July really yeah I
haven't seen it how long oh yeah it was
either a kite or might have had been a
message for help somebody would fly
there's a lot of folks signal a lot of
homeless people out there in Santa
Monica or even in Los all over Los
Angeles getting crazy man you think some
of these billionaires celebrities are
always complaining about it would let
them come stay with them you know yeah
I'm staying when your crew rooms
Chelsea Handler let them come live at
your [ __ ] [ __ ] house and drink half
your booze anyway obviously got a little
bit of anger in me yeah all right but
anyway let's crack into it
dog what do we got Dee huh well you have
a children's hat on let's don't pretend
that I'm going on
look I can't you look like you're
wearing Kimmy gibbler's hat bro that's
my joke
you look like punk rooster Cho okay okay
Punk Brewster dude you look like bebop
and rocksteady had a gay cousin you look
how you sell merch for kid and play what
are you wearing right now
you always have like that bro look at
you you look like a morning DJ back on
Cal said neither ride traffic wide open
door guards Billy were playing with
rocks you kids call footballs doctor I
ran the long neck last night broke the
Jews a DJ Aladdin if he came out of a
[ __ ] tank twinkled a transgender
magician you should go nuts
she gonna marry gots no talent she
called America's Got Talent like a
[ __ ] gay owl sick of freaking skies
so we get this guy a singer in a dick
sick of talking this human halfway house
over here oh my bad you call it long
necks yeah that goes - he's doing okay
bro yeah see he told me why we're gonna
make a wish situation like show he's
always it one time somebody thought he
was a parking meter and just came up and
put money in his mouth
no joke he weighs like sixty pounds dude
does he oh yeah oh yeah he does
you didn't just start a rap okay that's
good Oh Brendan just hopscotching
through the alphabet
[Music]